hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 2 hört zu und
spricht nach wie heißt du wie heißt du
ich heiße christina mettler
woher kommst du woher kommst du ich
komme aus österreich ich komme aus
österreich welche
sprachen sprichst du welche sprachen
sprichst du ich spreche deutsch ich
spreche deutsch und ein bisschen
englisch und ein bisschen englisch wo
wohnst du wohnst du ich wohne in
oerlikon
ich wohne in oerlikon
wie geht es ihnen wie geht es ihnen wie
geht es dir
wie geht es dir
mir geht es sehr gut
[Musik]
es sehr gut mir geht es nicht so gut
mir
geht es nicht so gut wie ist ihre
adresse
wie ist ihre adresse
wie ist deine adresse
meine adresse ist kurz straße 8 in
zürich
adresse ist kurz straße 8 in zürich wie
ist ihre telefonnummer wie ist ihre
telefonnummer wie ist deine
telefonnummer
wie ist deine telefonnummer
meine telefonnummer ist meine
telefonnummer ist sprichst
französisch sprichst du französisch ich
spreche französisch ich spreche
französisch sprichst du englisch
sprichst du englisch nein ich spreche
nicht englisch nein ich spreche nicht
englisch kommst du aus winterthur kommst
du aus winterthur
ja ich komme aus winterthur
nein ich komme nicht aus winterthur
das ist meine frau das ist meine frau
das ist mein mann das ist mein mann das
ist mein sohn das ist mein sohn das ist
meine tochter das ist meine tochter das
ist meine mutter das
ist meine mutter das ist mein vater das
ist mein vater das ist mein bruder das
ist mein bruder das ist meine schwester
das ist meine schwester zahlen eins bis
zwölf zahlen 1 bis 12 11 22 33 44 55 66
77 88 99 10 10 11 11 12
12 auf guten tag wie heißen sie
gerührt sie ich heiße peter müller
woher kommen sie
ich komme aus südafrika
wo wohnen sie
ich wohne in johannesburg welche sprache
sprechen sie ich spreche afrikaans wie
geht es ihnen
mir geht es nicht so gut
hallo
wie heißt du ich heiße manfred und du
ich heiße petra woher kommst du ich
komme aus england wo wohnst du ich wohne
im basel welche sprache sprichst du ich
spreche englisch und wie geht es dir
mir geht es fantastisch und dir
[Musik]